hi everyone and Heidi a I'd like to say
that I'm incredibly happy and honored to
be here to celebrate your 80th birthday
and to be among the speakers and I met
who as you know is 79 because i was at
Berkeley Singh from 79 to 1982 and it's
I cannot find words to say how
influential dick was on on me
professionally and on all of us at
Berkeley your inspiration to all of us
whether we were your students or we're
not your students and I still you know
the the community Berkeley at the time
was very close-knit the theory community
and we used to go to lunches at on
euclid to this cafe which I think was
named cafe des prés oh I think that was
the name it was a bunch of us in Manuel
and dig and Jean Lawler sometimes and we
they will talk about theory and the
recent results and they could ask all
kinds of penetrating questions and
probably as a as a person in that
stature you don't realize that every
word you say is a billy falls on very
acute listening ears and has a lot of
impact and there's a lot of significance
and I think that some questions that you
asked when we showed you some mental
poker protocol Sylvia and I originally
and we said that this I bid is hidden
you said well what about some exclusive
or of the bit you say oh yeah that's a
good question so then we went and asked
for and worked on it or then we had a
good mental poker protocol and you were
saying well maybe you have actually a
way here to hide a bit so you had these
observations which you know for us they
were fundamental and very guiding and
and if I had some words to describe you
I would say that you are incredibly wise
as you probably know or maybe you don't
know very wise very wise you always have
this very their universal view of things
even though you're a master of technique
so kind of a very intriguing combination
of actually seeing a big picture and yet
also being you know also master of
detail and you're very funny so you
where is a big thing that defines you
somehow was not mentioned today at least
not that but it's true but I guess
what's to mention it's just the fact
it's so obvious as if talking about dick
you have to think of his humor and you
had in my experience extremely open to
new ideas in which i think has been
always true and certainly true when this
whole cryptography thing was happening
at berkeley and very patient I felt I
don't know if you're patient in your
personal life but you were very patient
with us you know when we come and
explain all these very vague ideas and
you would listen and I heard from Mike
zipser that you told him maybe you don't
remember this is that it seems to be
beneficial but you have no idea what
they're talking about so thank you thank
you very much okay and I guess I I want
to say that Berkeley's always been a
wonderful place it still is but for me
it will always be the place of of dick
in Manuel and that's how it is in my
mind so I'm very happy to be here and
I'm also happy to be in this session
because you have been also father figure
for all of us so I guess Jeremy follows
after me so it's kind of fitting now I
want to say that not only one feels this
way so there is a few other people who
sent us the regards from MIT will need a
mic sip sir Silvio and I have some sound
here some of it is not working it's not
very impressive but I'll do it anyway
happy birthday dick so that's Mike and
now we'll need hi dick thank you for
everything for your research that
defined our field for your teaching
which captivated our imagination for
your support of young graduate students
for creating a hothouse of inspiration
creativity and excitement at Berkeley
happy birthday ok and here is this old
Oded for some reason sent a cat he says
he'd lost his voice so great and Silvio
actually sent a very long speech but it
was made for IBM and it doesn't work on
my mac so I'll send it to you personally
anyway so luckily I do have a few
minutes to speak myself so um ok so when
I was invited I was trying to decide
what to talk about
and I wanted to talk about something
that would interest akande connect up to
his work and that's not shouldn't be
hard because he's worked on so many
field and I've just enumerated hear the
things his contribution besides
np-hardness two algorithms you know
going graph algorithms of all sorts come
tutto optimization approximation
parallel randomized competitive and
online buy in computational biology so
what I've decided is instead of talking
about any any one of these I will talk
about work that in some sense is very
inspired by the kind of way that many of
these works evolved so often in almost
in many many obese papers is I think
Aurora already mentioned earlier today
nick says there's a problem and it's
hard it's either np-hard or maybe there
is a the best algorithm that's known is
NM for n vertices and M edges and then
he asks how can we do better so if it's
an np-hard problem how can we what kind
of distribution is over the inputs
average-case distribution that will
yield a polynomial time algorithm and if
it's an NML within what kind of average
case distribution again we do the linear
time algorithm and so forth so the work
that I'm going to talk about is goes
along in some sense a similar vein
except we are facing a situation where
there is no worse the worst case is
let's say NP hard and the average case
is also very hard then what do you do ok
and we'll tell you about some work
recent work about this problem with
Latino and rachel lynn and we call this
the algorithmic benefit of correlated
instances the choice is the name of the
paper is the complexity benefit of
correlate instances but since it's your
birthday I change it to the algorithmic
benefit a and an alternative title which
I'll touch on only at the end is why do
we spend time actually talking to each
other I mean it's a good question we
spend a lot of time talking to each
other is there a reason behind the other
just enjoyable which is also a good
reason but in any case so that's what
I'm going to speak about the algorithmic
benefit correlated instances so the idea
here is what we want to study just sort
of as a prelude is a situation where
we've got a problem and it's hard it's
hard in the worst carries its hard in
the average case what else can we do and
specifically we're going to look at a
situation where in a day
the instance that we're trying to solve
we may have some other correlated
instance of available to us how do we
take advantage of these extra instances
to make our problem easy and we'll see
the some situations where you take a
problem which is intractable if you just
have a single instance and if you're
given some correlated instances and I'll
define what i mean by correlated
instances it will become tractable okay
so actually this doesn't come from the
air if we think about factoring integers
then it's a well-known hard problem so
let's say if there's a number n product
of P Q then it's hard to find these
factors p and q but if for some reason
it's not clear how actually think I'm
going to come over here I don't know how
you can look at us in the screen at the
same time so I'm sorry so it's not
however if you are given a you're given
another number and Prime to the product
of the same prime P times some other
prime Q prime becomes really easy it
takes the greatest common divisor of N
and n prime and you can factor and
actually this type of correlation
between N and n prime was recently
exploited in the paper with Nadia
heninger and a lot of other people as a
lot couple other people where they
showed that in fact if you look at
cryptographic keys over the internet
lots of them have factors in common or
they have some correlations so they were
generated with the poor of Surat number
generator so that the composite numbers
which was supposed to be all hard in
isolation actually had enough structure
in relationship between each other so
that you could actually factor them
completely now this seems a very no
specialized problem some to break okay
it's algebraic sum one generated it
incorrectly the let's say these prime
divisors but the faces of this work is
that actually the situation is not so
we're so it's not so rare that the kind
of instances that we look at and want to
solve our may be correlated with each
other and we should take advantage of it
whenever we can so we want to think of
correlated instances is sort of a
phenomenon a in some examples even if we
don't just talk about doing it faster
algorithm we have instances and you want
a faster solution a we could think of in
about biology where if you want to learn
the mapping from genotype to phenotype
of an organism you
draw data for multiple specimens which
are correlated to each other and provide
you multiple correlated instances and
this is something that we can work with
in order to draw conclusions another
situation might be if you think about
error correcting codes we'd like to
correct as much as many errors as
possible but we're not just faced
necessarily with one document we may be
faced with a lot of versions of a
document all of which have errors but
they're correlated with each other and
that might help us to figure out faster
or more or more reliably wearers
occurred and then many many examples of
this sort that you can come up with on
your own so essentially more generally
would say that whenever instances are
derived in some sense from a source from
a single source we may treat them as
correlated and we try to solve them
together rather than solve them apart so
here's a nice picture which they do for
me I think and that is on the top there
is a source there's a bunch of instances
generated from the source each one on
its own might be difficult to solve come
up with a solution like from the red
pink green blue whatever it might be
each one individually or is easy and we
argue why don't we look at all these
instances together not the solutions
just the instances possibly then it
would be easier to find a solution so
there's a model here a more formally bar
than just in picture what is the models
we have some sort of generating process
where in the first step what it does is
it just like that's the ordinary
algorithmic story where you get there
some sort of a distribution some primary
distribution might be worst case might
be average case and this distribution
you from there comes the primary
instance so that's the usual come play a
job of an algorithm designer and let's
call this instance I and the solution s
okay so in a sense let's think that this
was generated by some process might be
worst-case process that generates the
instance and the solution and the new
thing is that we want to look at other
auxiliary instances and how are they
generated they again there is some
process generates I 1 through IT with
some underlying solutions s 1 through st
and we want this distribution to depend
both on the instance the primary
instance and the primary solution so
people I mean
it has been looked at you have an
instant you perturb it you see what
happens now we're not perturbing the
instance we are the generating process
is aware both of the instance and the
solution and creates a new distribution
of instances according which is depends
both on the solution and the instance so
when I say that we perturb what kind of
quarterly or they're correlated what
kind of correlation may be interesting
that's a good question the kind that
we're going to look at it this work is
going to be through some small
perturbation of the solution so if you
have let's say for example a graph with
a planted click you may think of
perturbing the click and looking at and
that will give you the new graph so the
two clicks and the two graphs may have a
large overlap or if you think about a
system of equations you may think of
look at the solution to the equations
and perturbing the solutions and that
yields a set of new equations for which
those new perturbed solutions are
solutions so why do we choose such a
strange definition one one thing the
factory example works this way right so
n is equal to P Q and the other end
prime is equal to P times Q prime it's
really the solutions are correlated it's
not clear that it's something that would
be necessarily it's not clear how to go
from end to end Prime in fact we know
that it's difficult so we don't want the
kind of perturbation that are easy to
get just from the instance because what
we would like to get is a real speed up
not just another poll not just a
polynomial speed up but really to be
able to go let's say from intractable to
tractable okay great so the focus of
this work is unconstrained satisfaction
problems so we choose a particular set
of problems and we show how this model
of correlated instances can yield you
know a speed up so what's constraint
satisfaction problems we all know they
capture case at many graph algorithms
system sparse equations and they entry
hard to solve and even NP hard to
approximate okay so constraint
satisfaction and also a conjecture to be
hard to solve on the average a so if we
liquid is a picture so pictorially with
a graph right so there's a bunch of this
graphic are these edges these blue edges
in the top there are the input bits in
the bottom there are the output bits and
the thing about this graph is that each
output node is a function over the small
number of input nodes so there's low
locality and then you label the output
nodes depending on what that predicate p
evaluated on those few locations gives
you and now the question you asked given
the graph and give it a labeling of the
output nodes Watson labeling of the
input node that yielded that labeling on
the output nodes okay so this is the
constraint satisfaction problem we're
looking at you know G the graph is known
the predicate is known the labels on the
Y's are known and we're asking is what
are the labels on the exes so in the
worst case these things are np-hard I
mean usually you think about is if all
the Y's are ones you satisfying all the
constraints but you also allow negation
so these things are not that different
from each other but we're looking let's
look also at an average case of this
question ok so what's an average CSP and
average CSP would go like this so there
is a description here in yellow of what
it is and that is where you choose the
graph at random ok so you fix the
predicate then you choose the graphic
random you choose the values of x at
random and then you compute what why is
so given that X has been chosen the
graph has been chosen it random the
predicate is fixed you value the
predicate of each one of the output
labels now it turns out that it's hard
to find the next we don't know how to
find an x satisfies all these
constraints or even approximated so this
is a hard problem a in fact goldrock
suggested to that this is one we
function let us give you an example of a
one-way function which is hard to invert
on the average so what about correlation
so these are my primary instances there
are these CSP instances and now I'm
asking what correlated instances may you
be given so that you would use in order
to solve that primary instance a so
here's a two models of correlation so
the first one is as I said given a graph
an X and a graph and a predicate and a y
computed it according to this x and y NP
take the X take every single bit of X
and
flip it with some small probability
something between zero and a half ok so
you perturb each bit slightly and now
this gives you a new auxiliary instance
and do this again you know put up again
put up again put your again always the
primary instance do it for a while and
this gives you let's say 10 zillion
turns 23 as many as you need yes a graph
is the same good so it would be better
if the graph was not the same but it's
the same a so that's one model the
second model and how gross my question
is still given Y and G and P find X ok
but this time you also given the y1 y2
y3 you know given any of the exes
another model which seems more less
natural but is going to be very
important is what i call the known
difference model in this model not only
that you're perturbed things and now
you're given the y i's you're actually
given the differences also you know
you're much luckier somebody tells you
what is the difference between X and X 1
X and X 2 X and X 3 and so forth so they
tell you these deltas now what and they
ask you the same question you know what
now I gave you extra information I gave
you the exes I gave you the deltas find
me the primary X so I why is that
reasonable that's a good question but I
think it is very reasonable the reason
is think about it again if you want to
sing back on in biology I was motivated
by launch Amir's talk that sometimes you
have an ability to perturb the solution
okay so it's not an incredible thing
that you can perturb in cryptography
something we call differential
cryptanalysis we call a tampering model
so this model is not a tampering model
it's not that you can say i want to
perturb the ice variable the jet
variable the case variable somebody did
this randomly but they told you what the
differences are but more importantly
whether this is a natural model or not
is that this will be a stepping stone
for us we will see that this model much
easier to work with and once you have a
solution worked out for this model you
can [ __ ] you can show how to sort of use
it as a solution for the first model
where you're not given the difference is
you're just given the perturbed
instances okay great so what can we show
so I know that this is just supposed to
be celebratory but you know since I
think this paper was rejected from Fox
this is my opportunity to revenge
um it's a good paper uh anyway so what
are the main results here okay okay so
what are the main results here so let me
just mention the three main results is a
few others but the first one says
essentially let's look at this random
CSP let's look at this random perturbed
solution model what can you do so what
we show is that if you're given law
again or login extra instances okay you
have n variables but you give an order
log in extra instances there is an
algorithm a polynomial time efficient
algorithm defines the solution that
satisfied essentially almost all the
constraints so you don't find exactly
but you find the solution that's where
that satisfies almost all the
constraints and in fact you can show
that it's pretty close to the original
solution in terms of Hamming distance
okay so that's good the second but this
is random CSP what can you do in the
case of worst case so you're given the
worst-case graph the worst case X okay
is there anything you can do and the
answer is that if you knew the
differences okay so for example for sent
a second now I'm making my life a little
easier I made a little harder because
the worst case incidents but I'm also
going to make it easier so I'm going to
give you not only those perturbations
but also the differences and it turns
out in this case we're really home free
that you can show that for any epsilon
between zero and a half and for any
density density I mean how many variable
constraints are there versus how many
variables you can actually find exactly
the solution a solution given order log
n perturbations okay so knowing the
differences is a huge help in fact I
will even give you a hint why know the
differences is a you tell moreover the
proof of the first theorem will be along
the lines of first we estimate the
differences and then we apply serum to
so knowing the differences is really the
right algorithmic machinery first you
find try to find the differences between
X these perturbations somehow estimate
them and then use them to solve your
primary instance okay so by the way
there's nothing he actually the idea
extends to locality which is not just
constant so far the constraint
satisfaction problem just took a
constant D you can think that is 510
whatever
but it extends to low locality so order
log in these peas they don't always have
to be the same predict it could be a
sequence of predicates of different p 1
p 2 on every output node so it's much
more general and yet this is somewhat
tight so there is actually predict there
are predicates p where you need there is
a constant C such as C log n it's not
going to be enough okay finally so I
said two things one first theorem says
you know if you have random
perturbations were for the average case
instance you can find the primary one as
long as you have ordered login of them
the second one said if you have the
known differences you can even do it in
the worst case and the third one says
well what about if you're only given one
single other instance can you do
anything then well it turns out to get
even then you can do something but it
has to be for special class of
predicates so therefore special class of
predicates which in some sense are
highly correlated with one of the
variables that predicate takes you can
even solve the problem using only one
additional predicate hey wanna district
or further perturb instance okay so some
idea why these correlations help and
then I almost be done am I supposed to
be done no I have a couple more minutes
right okay so some idea of why
correlation may help okay so remember
the picture the picture is that we have
we have these X's the reds and then we
have these blue edges that connect to
the wise a and our goal is to find X
okay we only know the X the wise and the
in the Blues right how it connects to
the X and then somebody gives me not
only gives me some perturbed instance y1
y2 y3 but I'm now showing you something
that's theorem 2 we're in a good
situation where somebody even told me
the differences so they even gave me the
deltas so no I just hope nobody talks to
me because it's not good once they start
talking to me okay um okay whatever so
so this is the situation right so if we
sort of focus on a particular location
of India in the Y string so that where i
marked it in yellow notice that
it only depends on those three locations
in X let's say the first one I think the
fifth and the sixth and it might change
or might not change and furthermore i'm
told exactly exactly what the difference
in the X is were so one kind of key
observation or one observation of key or
not but one observation is that if you
give an order log in instances okay then
clearly you are going to if you look at
this little those three bits you will Co
all possible shifts of these three bits
so you will see those bits plus 0 0 0
plus 0 0 1 plus 0 1 0 and so forth okay
we'll see all these shift and what that
tells you is it actually this could give
you an alternative essentially encoding
of X so we're trying to find X right and
I claim that this information leads to a
very natural encoding of X which will
call the shift encoding what do we mean
so another encoding of X is the value of
this predicate on X plus the shift Delta
okay in all possible deltas so for
example in this over here you know if
the coating of X and X prime are there
is a row these columns here so this is 1
column 1 encoding of X and another
encoding of it's kind of a different
encoding UX if this encoding is unique
okay so for some predicate this encoding
is unique and once this encoding is
unique we're sort of done why is that
because you know it's 2 to the D those
are all possible shift okay if I got all
the two to the day and it's unique now I
know exactly what X is but unfortunately
that's not true necessarily for some
credit case this is mapping is not one
to one and then the problem becomes
harder not much harder there's still
enough structure here and the structure
is that essentially you can show that
there's unique linear subspace that
contains the difference between X and X
prime for all those X and X prime they
have the same encoding and that in other
words means that you can write down a
system of linear equations the
particular vision wasn't linear a system
of linear equations on the bits of X and
you can solve them because we know how
to solve linear equations great so this
leads to an algorithm forget about the
algorithm let's just go on to the next
question which is harder and that is
what if we're not told the differences
the whole point here was that we are
told the differences okay what if you're
not told the differences what would you
do well you could hope to do the same
so saying okay so the input now is a
little worse so in other words I'm not
given these deltas I'm just given the
whys and I want to find the x's and as I
said it before so the thing to do is to
approximate the deltas why should you
even hope that you get sline in red
there why should you even hope that you
can approximate the differences because
in here because in some sense if you
look at the Y and its flipped all right
then any why is connected let's see 2 x
1 x 7 x 5 then you know the one of the
exes is flipped something has changed
about them and you have over constraints
you can take sort of a vote so there's
of a natural voting procedure which
would tell you whether X was changed or
not hence what is the Delta okay and in
fact that's a good idea you could do
some local them voting get an
approximation unfortunately this is not
such a good idea or at least it's not
sufficient because then eventually what
you have you have a whole bunch of
equations constraining X from one value
of the output and then another equations
constraining X for another value of the
output and so forth but this gives you a
system of noisy linear equations noisy
linear equation sort of notoriously hard
to deal with we base a lot of Krypton
this learning parity with noise lwe and
so forth so we're in trouble now we have
to do something more complicated which I
will not torture you with okay so what
are some questions you can ask and we
did ask some of them so one question
that is very natural is maybe it just
helped us correlation helped us because
we worked on this weird randomized CSP
so that's what we called a the develop
him what does ha hum you know from
Passover Seder says what does the bad
son ask a he asks why is it that you did
this it must be that it's not hard and
so forth that's the fox committee but in
case so say no no that's not it and
elite is not happy with my port
rejection anyways I know actually there
are actually instances to come out of a
Johan's reduction the PCP reduction
where you can show that perturbation
also will help so it's not the fact that
these are such a weird set of constraint
satisfaction problems another question
you asked that's correlation
always help and the answer is no and yes
no we can show instances where doesn't
help and yes I'll explain in a minute
why I say that I think it always helps
the third thing you can ask is what
about how much correlation Oh in some
sense correlation versus diversity so it
seems to be the case that in some sense
a look if you are completely had
correlated right that's not good enough
like if you're the same then you're not
it's no help if you are independent of
the other instance also it's not going
to be good enough so you know if you
look at the techniques this translates
to something more technical where we
actually need it in some sense a
difference between the instances in
order to compute sort of a derivative
going to which this function is changing
and if we had too much a too much
correlation we won't be able to detect
it and too little correlation we won't
be able to find any to find it so you
need it's a non-monotonic behavior I
think it's an interesting behavior to
study when does it become too much
correlation to be useful for paradigm
another thing is is this the only place
where correlation helps and I say no
there's actually examples and learn in
an example learning that we worked out
there's an example for planted click
graphs where this is useful and I
believe there would be others and then
finally I want to get to this question
of why did I say that this paper is
about why I talk to people okay so we're
going to go get to that in a minute so
just why did I say yes why did I say the
correlation always helps and there is
this the beautiful result on randomized
encoding by Applebaum wish I and Khushi
levites where they show that every
function can be converted to another
function that computes essentially the
same thing and it is hard to invert as
the original one but where the function
is local so instead of doing a very
complex computation it's a whole bunch
of small local computations such we can
show that their reductions you think any
function transform into that form now
breaks immediately with even one more
correlated instance so in a sense it's
not that difficulty of inverting that
computation that made correlation a that
make so in other words every function
regardless of how hard it is to solve
has a form which is amenable to
correlate
which can be sold in this correlated
model let's get to the end so what does
this have to do with collaboration and
talking to each other so the truth is
that I rate and i started this because
she was a visitor at MIT and he said
okay we are let's work on something and
we had to find an intersection so we
said you know it'd be interesting to
find out why do people benefit from
working together okay why do they even
talk to each other you know why do they
go to therapy you know what is the point
of worrying talking to another person
you could simulate the whole thing
yourself okay so we wanted to find some
kind of setting some kind of model where
you could actually prove that it's
beneficial to talk to each other and
what does this have to do with my talk
so if you think about it let's say that
I'm Alice and I have an input ok so
there's why there's everything I know of
myself but it's really there's a hidden
variable that I'd like to find out some
inner self discovery that I'm interested
in and we could think of this that
there's a function of the eight hidden
variable which is the outside so y is
equal to f of X ok x I don't know Andy
late Oh Bob no Barbara Barbara holds y
prime which is a function of X prime ok
so she has her hairy inner truth ok but
what she knows is y prime so is there
any point in the two of us talking to
each other way turns out that even if we
just tell each other what we know about
ourselves so I tell her my why she tells
me her y Prime voila we can discover our
internal truth as long as we act like a
constraint satisfaction problem which
you know I don't sure how how maybe and
the thing is that of course this doesn't
really answer the original question
you'll be much more interesting to find
a situation where you can prove that we
need to talk to each other in a more
complicated way like in an interactive
way but did I just tell her everything
about me but then we really have to
interact in order to get some
computational benefit so this is brings
me to the end I think we did show that
it's useful I think it is available
often these correlated instances and I
think it's useful to look for them in
order to solve your problem and most
important happy birthday dick and thank
you very much for everything
this paper yes they say did appear
somewhere even I mean folks is not the
only place in a pee it appeared in IT
yeah so in the learning in the in the
learning it's for learning parity with
noise so in learning theory people have
looked at correlated examples where the
examples are correlated here we want to
say the correlator concept so let's take
the two concepts the LPN the two
solutions are our perturbation job each
other and you get examples of the first
so equations in the first solution
equations in the second solution noise
equations and how can you do better and
there is a noise special like one in n
where we can do better than any bit
algorithm this move